Prima ancora che una donna dica "Mi
piaci". Le sue parole hanno già
trasmesso il messaggio e la maggior
parte degli uomini non lo coglie.
Esiste un divario tra ciò che le donne
dicono e ciò che provano realmente.
Proprio in questo divario, in tessuto
nelle conversazioni di tutti i giorni,
si trovano i segnali più chiari e
sinceri di una crescente attrazione.
La psicologia ha da tempo di la verità
emotiva traspare attraverso il
linguaggio, molto prima che la mente
cosciente se ne accorga.
Le donne sono particolarmente
predisposte
a elaborare ed esprimere gli stati
emotivi attraverso il modo in cui
parlano, attraverso la scelta delle
parole, attraverso ciò che decidono di
condividere e attraverso chi scelgono di
condividerlo.
Il significato che si cela dietro quelle
parole va ben oltre la superficie di una
singola frase. La dottoressa Ellen
Fischer, una delle principali
ricercatrici nel campo dei legami umani,
ha dimostrato che il linguaggio è uno
dei principali canali attraverso cui le
persone comunicano inconsciamente il
proprio coinvolgimento emotivo.
molto prima che una donna si renda conto
consapevolmente di provare dei
sentimenti per qualcuno, il suo cervello
li trasmette già attraverso il modo
specifico in cui parla, gli argomenti
che predilige e la quantità di sé che
decide di confidare a quella persona.
Quindi, se vi state chiedendo se
qualcuno nella vostra vita stia
sviluppando dei veri sentimenti per voi,
smettete di aspettare una dichiarazione
esplicita e iniziate ad ascoltare
attentamente i segnali più sottili. Alla
fine di questo video saprete esattamente
quali frasi indicano che il mondo
emotivo di una donna si sta già
orientando verso di voi. Ho riservato il
segnale più importante per la fine, un
segnale che una volta compreso cambierà
per sempre il vostro modo di ascoltare
ogni conversazione.
Restate sintonizzati perché ciò che
verrà alla fine potrebbe stravolgere
tutto ciò che credevate di sapere già.
Uno, sinceramente ho la sensazione di
conoscerti da sempre. Quando una donna
ti dice una cosa del genere, non
liquidarla come una semplice
osservazione di circostanza.
Quello che stai ascoltando è un segnale
psicologico,
una finestra diretta sul territorio
emotivo in cui si è già silenziosamente
addentrata.
Questa frase non emerge a caso.
Appare quando una donna ha oltrepassato
una soglia interiore invisibile, quando
ha smesso di considerarti una persona
nuova e ha iniziato a collocarti in una
categoria ben più significativa,
quella di qualcuno che sente già di
appartenere al suo mondo.
Gli psicologi descrivono questo fenomeno
come compressione temporale,
l'esperienza in cui una profonda
familiarità emotiva annulla la
percezione della durata di una
relazione.
Quando una persona si sente veramente
compresa, il tempo perde il suo peso
abituale. Le settimane iniziano a
sembrare anni.
Poche conversazioni autentiche e sincere
assumono la risonanza emotiva di una
storia condivisa molto più lunga. Quando
una donna ti esprime direttamente questa
sensazione, ti sta dicendo che stare con
te ti permette di evitare la solita
fatica di costruire la fiducia da zero,
perché in qualche modo quella fiducia
sembra già meritata.
Immagina, vi frequentate solo da poche
settimane. Una sera, a metà di una
frase, lei si ferma, ti guarda e dice a
bassa voce: "So che sembra strano, ma
onestamente ho la sensazione di
conoscerti da tutta la vita". Quella
pausa, quella confessione è il suo mondo
interiore che si riorganizza
silenziosamente in base alla tua
presenza.
Quando una donna ti dice di averti
sempre conosciuto, il suo cuore è già
arrivato in un luogo dove le sue parole
non sono ancora giunte.
Come rispondere?
Mantieni un atteggiamento cordiale con i
piedi per terra e autentico.
Prova con alcune relazioni saltano tutti
i passaggi usuali. So esattamente cosa
intendi. Questo convalida il sentimento
senza creare pressione, segnalando al
contempo, in modo discreto che anche da
parte tua il legame è altrettanto
autentico.
Due, sei davvero diventato una delle
persone più importanti della mia vita.
È qui che molti uomini commettono un
grave errore.
Sentendo le parole intimo o amico vanno
subito in tilat. presumono di essere
stati definitivamente relegati nella
categoria sbagliata e iniziano a
ritirarsi proprio nel momento meno
opportuno.
Ma fermatevi un attimo prima che questa
convinzione prenda piede.
Quando una donna vi include tra le
persone a lei più care, soprattutto in
questa fase iniziale della relazione,
non sta chiudendo una porta, ne sta
aprendo una. Nelle donne la vicinanza
emotiva precede sempre la profondità
romantica,
non passerà dalla prima impressione a un
vero e proprio coinvolgimento
sentimentale
senza prima aver costruito una solida
base di fiducia. Quindi quando ti dice
che sei già diventato una delle persone
a lei più care, in realtà sta
comunicando che ha esteso il suo accesso
a una parte di sé che la maggior parte
delle persone nella sua vita non
raggiungerà mai. Presta attenzione ai
segnali comportamentali.
Ti sta confidando cose insolitamente
personali? Ti chiede un parere su
decisioni che per lei sono davvero
importanti? ti sta confidando i suoi
dubbi, le sue paure, le cose che non
rivela facilmente alla maggior parte
delle persone che la circondano.
Questi non sono i segni di una semplice
amicizia,
sono i segnali di una vera intimità
emotiva che si sta sviluppando in tempo
reale. La dimensione romantica si
costruisce proprio su queste basi.
Quando lo dice, mantieni la calma, prova
con sinceramente questo per me significa
più di tanti complimenti. Una
connessione autentica come questa non
capita spesso.
In questo modo hai rafforzato il legame
senza forzarne l'etichetta, lasciandole
lo spazio per riflettere sulla sua vera
natura.
Tre. Sei semplicemente diverso da
chiunque io abbia mai conosciuto e non
riesco a spiegarmi bene il perché.
Questa frase ha una carica elettrica
molto particolare.
Quando una donna ti dice che sei
diverso, soprattutto quando non riesce a
spiegarne appieno il motivo, diventi per
lei oggetto di un autentico fascino.
L'attrazione si basa in parte sulla
novità e in parte sul contrasto.
E quando una donna non riesce a
individuare la fonte precisa di ciò che
continua ad attrarla verso di te,
significa che la sua curiosità è al
massimo e non smetterà di indagare su
questo aspetto.
Gli psicologi comportamentali
descrivono questo fenomeno come
l'effetto contrasto,
il modo in cui un individuo specifico
può distinguersi così nettamente dalle
esperienze precedenti di qualcuno che il
cervello inizia ad attribuirgli
un'importanza maggiore.
Non ti sta paragonando ad altri uomini
per cattiveria.
lo fa perché ha interrotto uno schema
interno familiare e la sua mente sta
cercando di capire esattamente
perché questa interruzione le risulti
così attraente. Quando ciò accade, non
affrettarti a dare troppe spiegazioni.
Seconda piuttosto la curiosità
di qualcosa del tipo forse la domanda
più interessante non è cosa mi renda
diversa, ma perché questo ti sembra
importante? Questo semplice cambio di
prospettiva reindirizza la conversazione
verso i suoi sentimenti, invitandola ad
esaminarli più attentamente.
E più attentamente li esamina, più
rafforza ciò che sta già iniziando a
percepire.
4.
Non devo recitare una parte davanti a
te, posso semplicemente essere me
stesso.
Di tutte le frasi in questa lista,
questa è quella che ha il peso emotivo
maggiore,
perché al di là del tono disinvolto con
cui viene pronunciata, ciò che ti sta
realmente dicendo è questo: hai compiuto
qualcosa di veramente straordinario.
sei guadagnato l'accesso al suo vero io
senza filtri e senza difese.
Ognuno di noi indossa una corazza
sociale.
Tutti presentiamo al mondo versioni di
noi stessi attentamente calibrate,
plasmate da ciò che crediamo gli altri
vogliano vedere, trovino accettabile o
approvino.
Ma quando qualcuno ci fa sentire
veramente al sicuro, abbastanza al
sicuro da smettere del tutto di recitare
una parte, accade qualcosa di
straordinario.
Non ci sentiamo semplicemente a nostro
agio, ci sentiamo compresi ed essere
veramente compresi, anziché
semplicemente osservati, è una delle
cose più profonde che una persona possa
offrire a un'altra. La donna che ti
permette di vederla senza alcuna
protezione ha già deciso in un luogo
intimo e silenzioso dentro di sé che tu
vali il rischio. Gli psicologi la
chiamano presenza autentica, la rara e
specifica esperienza di essere
completamente se stessi in compagnia di
un'altra persona senza il peso di un
costante autocontrollo o di un'auto
censura.
Quando una donna raggiunge questo stato
con te, il suo coinvolgimento emotivo
non è superficiale o passeggero,
è fondamentale.
Sei diventato, senza necessariamente
volerlo, un luogo in cui si sente
veramente al sicuro. E una volta che
qualcuno ha trovato questo tipo
specifico di sicurezza con un'altra
persona, diventa molto difficile
allontanarsene.
La risposta giusta non è un grande
discorso, è uno specchio.
Siate autentici a vostra volta,
condividete qualcosa di spontaneo sulla
vostra esperienza.
che l'onestà sia reciproca, non a senso
unico, perché nel momento in cui due
persone smettono contemporaneamente di
recitare una parte l'una per l'altra,
ciò che esiste tra loro cessa di essere
una situazione piacevole e inizia a
diventare qualcosa a cui nessuna delle
due vuole rinunciare.
Prima di proseguire, se questo video sta
cambiando il tuo modo di pensare alle
conversazioni,
prenditi 2 secondi e metti "Mi piace"
subito.
È davvero importante per il canale di
psicologia femminile e ci aiuta a
continuare a creare contenuti che
abbiano un impatto reale.
Ora andiamo avanti.
Cinque.
Parlare con te è la prima volta che ho
la sensazione che qualcuno mi capisca
davvero.
Nella nostra vita la maggior parte delle
persone ascolta per rispondere, un
numero ben minore ascolta per capire
e il numero di persone capaci di far
sentire un'altra persona non solo
ascoltata, ma veramente compresa, è
davvero esiguo.
Quando una donna ti dice che le
conversazioni con te la fanno sentire
veramente capita, non sta descrivendo
una semplice preferenza,
sta nominando una delle esperienze
emotivamente più significative che un
essere umano possa vivere.
La ricerca in psicologia relazionale di
costantemente che sentirsi compresi, non
semplicemente ascoltati, ma capiti a
fondo, è uno dei più potenti
catalizzatori per l'attaccamento
romantico.
Col tempo questo legame va ben oltre
l'attrazione fisica, il senso
dell'umorismo condiviso o gli interessi
comuni.
Quando una donna individua qualcuno che
sa ascoltare i suoi pensieri senza
immediatamente reindirizzarli,
minimizzarli o affrettarsi a risolverli,
inizia ad associare quella persona a una
qualità di appagamento emotivo che
diventa molto difficile da trovare
altrove. Ecco come di solito si svolge
la scena.
Lei condivide qualcosa di autentico,
un ricordo complesso, una paura
silenziosa,
una speranza che non ha espresso a molte
persone.
Tu ascolti senza interromperla, le
riporti le sue parole con sincera
curiosità e le poni un quesito che
chiarisca che hai seguito ogni sua
parola.
Poi in una conversazione successiva
fai riferimento casualmente a qualcosa
che ha accennato di sfuggita e il modo
in cui la sua espressione cambia in quel
momento ti dice molto più di qualsiasi
confessione diretta. Quando te lo dice,
non sviare la conversazione,
ascoltala direttamente.
Prova a dire voglio davvero capire chi
sei veramente. Non solo la versione che
ti senti al sicuro a mostrare alla
maggior parte delle persone.
Questo denota una reale intenzione.
Le fa capire che ciò che ha vissuto è
stato intenzionale, non accidentale.
C'è qualcosa nello stare con te che va
oltre ogni mia capacità di descrizione?
Presta molta attenzione quando una donna
usa la parola più profondo per
descrivere come percepisce la tua
presenza.
Non si tratta di un'espressione comune.
Emerge quando qualcuno ha bisogno di
parole per descrivere una qualità di
connessione che semplicemente non
rientra in nessuna delle categorie.
che applica alle persone nella sua vita.
Ciò che sta comunicando è specifico.
Non si tratta di attrazione
superficiale, né di semplice
compatibilità,
né del normale piacere di trascorrere
del tempo insieme. Sta descrivendo una
risonanza, una sensazione tattile che
qualcosa tra voi due esista a un livello
che raramente, se non mai, sperimenta
con altre persone. Gli psicologi
descrivono questo fenomeno come
risonanza limbica. L'allineamento
degli stati emotivi di due persone che
produce la sensazione di essere in
perfetta sintonia
non può essere creata o indotta
artificialmente.
O esiste tra due persone o non esiste.
Quando una donna lo percepisce con
sufficiente chiarezza da nominarlo in
una conversazione,
ha raggiunto un livello di onestà
emotiva che semplicemente non concede
alle persone in cui non è veramente
coinvolta.
Come rispondere senza esagerare?
semplicemente confermando.
D anch'io provo esattamente la stessa
cosa e onestamente il fatto che sia
difficile da esprimere a parole potrebbe
essere proprio ciò che lo rende reale.
Hai confermato l'esperienza condivisa,
hai comunicato che è reciproca e hai
lasciato abbastanza spazio per far sì
che lei continui a pensarci.
7.
Ho la sensazione di poterti dire
letteralmente qualsiasi cosa. Questa
frase segnala qualcosa di completamente
diverso da tutto ciò che l'ha preceduta.
Non riguarda la risonanza emotiva o un
senso di profondità,
riguarda il permesso,
la specifica autorizzazione interiore
che una donna si concede per essere
pienamente presente, pienamente onesta e
completamente senza filtri. con un altro
essere umano. Pensate a quanto siano
selettive la maggior parte delle persone
riguardo a chi rivela la loro vera
essenza, senza filtri.
Persino con le persone che amano
profondamente,
molti mostrano solo una versione
edulcorata e addolcita di sé. La
versione più autentica e genuina rimane
nascosta a quasi tutti.
Quando una donna vi dice che si sente di
potervi confidare qualsiasi cosa, vi sta
inserendo in una delle cerchie più
ristrette e significative della sua
vita.
Le prove comportamentali sono leggibili
una volta che si sa cosa cercare.
Ti contatta per cose che in apparenza
sembrano insignificanti, ma che
chiaramente hanno un peso personale.
Ti chiede un parere sincero su cose che
la spaventano davvero. Ti mostra le
parti contraddittorie, irrisolte e
disordinate di sé, senza nasconderle
prima.
Ognuno di questi gesti rappresenta un
atto di intimità emotiva che va ben
oltre la semplice amicizia.
Rispondi in modo da rispettare ciò che
ti sta offrendo. Voglio essere una
persona per cui non dovrai mai
censurarti.
Qualunque cosa tu mi porti la tratterò
con cura.
Questo le farà capire che l'accesso che
ti sta concedendo non verrà usato in
modo improprio e più si sentirà sicura
di questo, più si fiderà di te e ti
affiderà ciò che normalmente tiene
nascosto.
Bonus.
Continua a pensare a te anche quando non
lo vorrei.
Quando una donna lo ammette, che sia in
modo diretto o velato da frasi come "Ogi
mi sei venuto in mente all'improvviso"
o "Qual mi ha ricordato la nostra
conversazione",
tu smetti di essere una presenza
marginale nel suo mondo emotivo.
Diventi una figura ricorrente nella sua
vita interiore. Qualcuno a cui la sua
mente ritorna senza bisogno di essere
indirizzata.
Gli psicologi identificano l'attenzione
mentale involontaria e ricorrente verso
una persona specifica come uno dei
principali indicatori della formazione
di un legame emotivo.
La mente non torna a chiunque, è
attratta da persone che sono arrivate a
rappresentare qualcosa di essenziale,
sicurezza. eccitazione,
la sensazione di essere veramente visti,
la percezione che qualcosa di
significativo e raro possa essere
possibile. Quando i pensieri di una
donna continuano a tornare a te, anche
mentre sta facendo qualcosa di
completamente diverso, è un segnale che
è passata dal semplice apprezzamento
della tua compagnia al desiderio
autentico della tua presenza.
lo riconoscerai dal modo in cui ti
contatterà, non per fare progetti, non
perché le serva qualcosa di pratico, ma
semplicemente perché le è successo
qualcosa durante la giornata e il suo
istinto immediato è stato quello di
raccontartelo.
Quell'impulso è il segnale stesso.
significa che sei già intrecciato al
tessuto della sua esperienza quotidiana,
non perché abbia deciso consapevolmente
di metterti lì, ma perché ci sei
arrivato da solo e lei non sta facendo
nulla per allontanarti?
Quando te lo dice, rispondi in modo
semplice e sincero.
Mi hai fatto davvero piacere, ti ho
pensato anch'io.
Nessuna strategia,
nessuna recita,
solo una sincera reciprocità.
Perché nel momento in cui due persone
smettono di fingere di non pensare
costantemente l'una all'altra, quello è
esattamente il momento in cui inizia
qualcosa di vero.
Se siete arrivati fino a questo punto,
scrivete ora capisco nei commenti qui
sotto.
È così che so che siete il tipo di
persona che presta davvero attenzione a
ciò che la maggior parte delle persone
ignora completamente.
L'attrazione non si manifesta mai con
una singola eclatante dichiarazione.
Arriva attraverso le parole specifiche
che una persona continua a scegliere
quando è in tua compagnia. frasi che
rivelano i suoi sentimenti ben prima che
abbia la chiarezza o il coraggio di
esprimerli direttamente.
Questi sette segnali rappresentano il
linguaggio completo di questo processo e
ora sai esattamente come interpretarli
tutti.
Se questo video ti ha fatto riflettere,
metti mi piace e iscriviti a Feminine
Psychology per ricevere ogni settimana
altri spunti come questo.
Condividilo con chi sta cercando di
capire cosa prova una donna per lui, ma
non ci riesce ancora del tutto. Potresti
offrirle la prospettiva che le mancava.
Il prossimo video pensato appositamente
per te in questo momento ti aspetta già
sullo schermo. M.